und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend auf
den Tag zwei Monate ist es her dass der
Chef der berüchtigten wagnergruppe
Goschin eine Art Rebellion versuchte und
mit seinen seltenen auf Moskau zu
marschiertem viele Russland Kenner haben
danach prognostiziert dass der Mann kein
langes Leben mehr haben werde manche
wunderten sich dass Putin ihn nicht
sofort beseitigte wie so viele andere
vor Ihnen nun aus einem Fenster gefallen
ist prigoshi nicht aber mutmaßlich vom
Himmel
zumindest stand er auf der
Passagierliste eines Flugzeuges das
heute abend in Russland abgestürzt ist
was bisher bekannt ist fast Christian
von Rechenberg zusammen
dies ist das letzte bekannte Bild
gregorzins aus einem Video Ort unbekannt
wie so oft er spricht über einen Einsatz
in Afrika nun soll er tot sein
abgestürzt als einer von zehn
Passagieren auf einem Flug von Moskau
nach St Petersburg in der Region schwer
soll die Maschine vom Himmel gefallen
sein wie diese Bilder im Internet
belegen sollen die Absturzstelle Folter
auch diese Bilder noch nicht verifiziert
die ersten Leichen seien bereits
gefunden und geborgen
prigoschin der unberechenbare vor knapp
zwei Monaten zettelt er mit seinen
Wagner Söldnern einen Putsch gegen Putin
an und unterliegt muss fliehen nach
Belarus behauptet jedenfalls der dortige
gemacht habe zuvor gelangten bregosch
ins Panzer bis nach bodonisch der Weg
nach Moskau schien frei die genauen
Umstände warum brigosch in seine Söldner
stoppte nicht bekannt bekannt hingegen
seine Wutausbrüche im Kampf vom bachmut
Spielen seine selten eine wichtige Rolle
doch der Chef sieht sie als
Kanonenfutter verheizt was ich sonst
keiner traut rigosch in wütet gegen
Putins Militärführung und damit auch
gegen ihn
werfen
das sind Väter das sind Söhne und diese
Ärsche die uns keine Munition geben
die sollen in der Hölle schmoren
Soldaten und nutzt den Moment zum
Nachtreten
in bachmut kämpften wir nicht nur gegen
die Streitkräfte der Ukraine sondern
auch gegen die russische Bürokratie die
uns Stein in den Weg legte
die Gruppe Wagner Ex-Soldaten und
rekrutierte Häftlinge wie ihr Chef
brigoshin brutal und rücksichtslos
gegründet 2014 sie ist eine nicht
staatliche paramilitärische Organisation
die bisher skrupellos russische
Interessen im Ausland durchgesetzt hat
unter anderem in Syrien und Mali der
Name Wagner soll von einem Mitbegründer
stammen der eine Vorliebe für den
deutschen Komponisten gehabt haben soll
der Absturz brigoschins war es Putins
späte Rache an einem Widersacher der zu
weit ging war es Zufall oder tatsächlich
ein Fehler von Maschine oder Material es
gibt viele Fragen und kaum Antworten
womöglich wird das auch so bleiben
wir noch zu unserem Korrespondenten
Armin Körper Armin welche Informationen
gibt es zu der ganzen Sache in Moskau
die russische Luftfahrtbehörde bestätigt
dass die Maschine abgestürzt ist dass an
Bord 10 Personen waren und dass die alle
mittlerweile auch geborgen wurden die in
vor wenigen Minuten hat die
Luftfahrtbehörde auch bestätigt dass an
bordhin der Führer der wagnergruppe war
und seine rechte Hand Dimitri utkin es
wird jetzt hier viel spekuliert darüber
was die Ursache dieses Flugzeugabsturzes
war erste quellenberufen sich auf die
Luftfahrtbehörde das hat die aber uns
gegenüber nicht bestätigt es aber eine
Explosion an Bord gegeben andere
experten mutmaßen darüber es könnte auch
sein dass eine Luftabwehrrakete das
Flugzeug bewusst oder versehentlich
abgeschossen hätte die interessante
Frage für uns ist jetzt natürlich wie
geht's mit der wagnergruppe weiter die
beiden Führer sind offensichtlich ums
Leben gekommen das heißt wie kann diese
Truppe weiter bestehen ich höre dass es
eine Art havarieplan gibt hier an die
Kommandeure wie in einem solchen Fall zu
verfahren ist der havarieplan ist aber
im Moment noch deren Geheimnis und der
krimin hält sich zu all dem auch noch
bedeckt
der Kreml hält sich in Schweigen es gibt
gar keine Meldungen aus dem Kreml keine
Bestätigung keine Dementis nichts
interessant ist natürlich der Zeitpunkt
das vor genau zwei Monaten
pregorien diesen Putsch angezettelt
haben soll und interessant ist auch das
Präsident Putin zurzeit des Absturzes
Kriegsveteran aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
von der Schlacht vom Kurs ausgezeichnet
hat das gilt in der Geschichtsschreibung
hier als eine der entscheidenden
Schlachten gegen Nazi Deutschland
Armin danke schön nach Moskau
und dann blicken wir jetzt erstmal nach
Deutschland das Kabinett hat heute
getagt und auch getan was man
üblicherweise erwartet Gesetzentwürfe zu
verabschieden sollen auch keine
unfreundlichen Worte gefallen sein dafür
ist der quasi öffentliche kabinettsaal
eh der falsche Ort aber natürlich
schweben über dieser Koalition schon
wieder dunkle Wolken just als der grüne
Vizekanzler im Urlaub war sorgte er
seine Parteifreundin Familie Ministerin
Paulus für den nächsten Koalitionskrach
und blockiert ein Gesetz dem Habeck
selbst zuvor zugestimmt hatte er ist
heute den ersten Tag zurück und in dem
Interview dass ich vorhin mit ihm
geführt habe wollte ich natürlich wissen
wie er diesen Move seiner Parteifreundin
fand zunächst berichtet Karl
Hinterleitner aus Berlin
es geht um zwei verschiedene Gesetze
deren Vermischung und die nächste Runde
im Ampel Streik Lisa Paust will für ihre
Kinder Grundsicherung möglichst viel
Geld Christian Lindner will das Geld
möglichst zusammenhalten bei der
Finanzierung klappen die Vorstellungen
also weit auseinander ein Ringen um
Milliarden seit Wochen schon es ist auch
klar dass die zwei Milliarden ist auch
nicht sein werden sondern dass wir über
tatsächliche Leistungsverbesserungen
gegen Kinderarmut sprechen und es gibt
ja jetzt noch ein paar Mehrkosten und
wir werden sicherlich es wird
wahrscheinlich eine Summe sein zwischen
zwei und zwölf ich glaube so viel kann
ich heute abend sagen womöglich nah an
die 12 Milliarden zu kommen markiert die
Ministerin das Ende der Sommerpause mit
einem Paukenschlag sie lässt Lindners
Wachstumschancen gesetzt mit ihm die
Grünen eigentlich einen verstanden waren
vor ist scheitern mit dem Gesetz wollte
der Finanzminister über steuerpolitische
Maßnahmen und einer Prämie bei
Klimaschutz Investitionen die Wirtschaft
entlasten um rund 6,5 Milliarden Euro
was das mit der aber Grundsicherung zu
tun hat erstmal gar nichts die FDP
empört ich halte wenig davon Gesetze
gegenseitig sozusagen zu blockieren
sondern es geht ja um folgendes die
Kinderarmut resultiert ja oftmals aus
der Arbeitslosigkeit der Eltern insofern
ist es gerade zu falsch das
wachstumschancengesetz des
Finanzministers zu blockieren was ja
mehr Job schaffen soll also als
Familienministerin hätte ich mir
eigentlich gewünscht dass Frau Pause
sagt jawohl wir brauchen mehr Wachstum
da geht es Kindern in Deutschland auch
besser Lisa Pause heute gemeinsam mit
Marco Buschmann es geht um
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das kostet wenig
und bringt daher keinen Streit bei der
Kindergrundsicherung hat sie ihre
Forderung inzwischen auf sieben
Milliarden Euro heruntergeschraubt sagen
will sie dazu nicht
die Kinder Grundsicherung stand heute
nicht auf der Tagesordnung aber wir
werden heute nur darüber sprechen ein
Treffen mit Lindner und Scholz soll
jetzt die Klärung bringen der Kanzler
wollte eigentlich das Schluss ist mit
solchen Krisengesprächen doch vor zehn
Tagen im Sommer Interview war er
zuversichtlich die Ampel werde ab jetzt
besser miteinander umgehen ich wünschte
mir dass das im Ton manchmal anders
stattfindet als es in der Vergangenheit
war und habe auch den Eindruck dass über
den Sommer sich viele vorgenommen haben
das genau zu ändern daraus ist erstmal
nichts geworden und als wäre das alles
nicht genug gibt es auch noch beim
zentralen Regierungsprojekt Klimapolitik
Gegenwind ausgerechnet von
Umweltverbände
es ist schön geredet man hat ja auch in
den projektionsberichten alle möglichen
Maßnahmen mit einkalkuliert die so nicht
kommen werden wie zum Beispiel ein
verbessertes Gebäude Energiegesetz was
auch noch zeitlich nach hinten
verschoben worden ist und der
Verkehrssektor ist besonders verteilt
denn da stehen eigentlich keine wirklich
handfesten Maßnahmen drin damit lassen
sich die Klimaziele nicht erreichen
interner Streit vor vielen der
Umweltziele die fortschrittskoalition
tut sich schwer mit dem eigenen
Fortschritt
Vizekanzler ist zugeschaltet guten Abend
wir sind gerade aus dem Urlaub zurück
wie schön ist das denn wenn man im
Urlaub da mit quasi aufwacht dass eine
Parteifreunde den nächsten großen
Konflikt in der Koalition vom Zaun
gebrochen hat
ja nichts zu tun das ist natürlich jetzt
kein Glanzstück gewesen
andererseits kommt das
Wachstumsbeschleunigungsgesetz jetzt in
der kabinettsäuren mieseberg und auch
bei der Kindergrundsicherung sind wir
auf guten Weg also wenn man mal jetzt
den Streit beiseite lässt kein Schaden
in der Sache wir kriegen das alles gut
hin na ja sie sagen kann Glanzstück das
ist natürlich
ich sag meine Verniedlichung dessen was
da eigentlich passiert ist also in ihrer
Abwesenheit hintergeht quasi eine
Parteifreundin sie und blockiert ein
Gesetz dem der Kanzler der Vizekanzler
und der Finanzminister bereits
zugestimmt hatten das kann doch
eigentlich nicht sein oder
wie gesagt das Gesetz ist ja jetzt nur
aufgeschoben überhaupt nicht aufgehoben
es ist ein Gesetz dass jetzt nachdem wir
das doch ein bisschen kalibriert haben
gute Impulse setzt ich bin damit ganz
zufrieden es wird auch kommen und es
wird dann den Deutschen Bundestag quasi
in den ersten Sitzungswochen erreichen
also in der Sache ist kein Schaden
entstanden aber ja es ist natürlich
genau das wieder passiert was diese
Regierung bei wie ich finde eigentlich
gute Arbeit in der Sache immer wieder
auszeichnet sich nämlich selber Beine zu
stellen also das ist sehr ärgerlich weil
es immer in diesen Eindruck des Streites
hat der ist jetzt da wieder entstanden
aber in der Sache selbst werden wir
diesen diesen diesen Impuls setzen für
die deutsche Wirtschaft dass mir extrem
wichtig es geht ja am Ende um die Sache
naja es ist aber schon symptomatisch
also offenbar gibt es in ihrer Partei
eine ganz erhebliche Wut darüber wie
diese Koalition läuft und der Wunsch an
der Stelle dann irgendwo auch mal mit
der Faust auf den Tisch zu schlagen ohne
Rücksicht auf Verluste und es ist nicht
ganz klar wo jetzt eigentlich das macht
Zentrum bei den Grünen ist also wer bei
ihnen denn eigentlich den Kurs bestimmt
[Applaus]
also die Grünen haben in den letzten
zwei Jahren so viele Entscheidungen
getroffen die nicht in unserem
Wahlprogramm stehen die aber wichtig
waren für das Land und die Stabilität
des Landes das ist er herausragend ist
wie wir uns in die Verantwortung
hineinbegeben haben und ja an der Stelle
hat man nicht geklappt aber da mag
sicherlich auch Frust oder falsche
Taktik eine Rolle gespielt haben aber
insgesamt ist ja doch festzustellen dass
wir in den letzten anderthalb Jahren
sehr viele unangenehme Entscheidungen
selbstbewusst und aus dem Wissen heraus
dass sie notwendig sind getroffen haben
und deswegen würde ich sie nicht
verallgemeinern an der Stelle das
unangenehme ist nur für die
Ampelkoalition das gilt für alle drei
Parteien dass dieser Eindruck dass da
gute Sacharbeit leistet wurde bei der
Bevölkerung überhaupt nicht ankommt also
gut man kann auch immer sagen Umfragen
sind Momentaufnahme aber wenn dann in
einem Politbarometer über 80% sagen
diese Koalition kommt überhaupt nicht
voran dann ist das ja ein wahnsinnig
ja dem stimme ich zu und stimmen
natürlich auch mit der Wirklichkeit
nicht überein wir kommen ja voran wir
haben gerade heute das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht modernisiert
Deutschland wird noch attraktiver für
Menschen die zu uns kommen die
Integrationsleistung wird noch mal
gesteigert einen Schritt würde ich sagen
der lange überfällig war und den in am
Ende nur diese Regierungskonstellation
gehen konnte also wir machen lauter
wichtige Dinge die auch dem Anspruch den
wir selbst gestellt haben nämlich
moderne moderne Regierung zu sein
fortschrittskoalition zu seinen gerecht
wird aber sie haben völlig recht wir
versauen ist uns permanent selbst und
das ist natürlich auf Dauer kein
Erfolgsgeheimnis warum sagen die
Experten vom Klimarat dass die
Bundesregierung ihre selbst gesteckten
Klimaziele nicht erreichen wird also
dann scheint ja doch nicht so voran zu
gehen wie sie es jetzt darstellen
na die sagen können das gleiche was ich
gesagt habe als ich diesen Bericht
vorgestellt habe wir haben die Lücke die
wir geerbt haben die ich geerbt habe um
80% verkleinert 80 % sind nicht 100% das
stimmt vor allem im Verkehrsbereich
reichen die Maßnahmen nicht das liegt
daran dass wir beim Schmieden dieser
Koalition im Koalitionsvertrag bestimmte
Dinge ausgeschlossen haben von
Tempolimit bis zu Steuererhöhung das
damit werden jetzt irgendwie umgehen
müssen aber das ist jetzt irgendwie auch
keine Überraschung gewesen dass diese
80% nicht 100% sind das habe ich ja
selber gesagt trotzdem
[Musik]
ich will das überhaupt nicht schön reden
ja aber trotzdem ist es zum ersten Mal
und das sagt der Expertenrat auch
überhaupt wieder möglich geworden dass
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland die
Klimaschutzziele einhalten kann 100
Prozent werden besser gewesen aber
immerhin sind wir doch deutlich voran
gekommen und das ist ein Arbeitsauftrag
für die Zukunft entweder noch Dinge sich
auszudenken die uns an die 100%
ranbringen oder in der Umsetzung
schneller zu werden das wäre ja auch
eine Möglichkeit und diese Möglichkeit
sollten wir ergreifen
zweifelt ja dass das alles umgesetzt und
sagt vor allem das Leben zum Teil ganz
unterschiedliche Ausgangsbasen
herangezogen also das
Verkehrsministerium sagt zu den CO2
Einsparung von dem Klima Ticket z.B
Deutschland Ticket etwas ganz anderes
als das Wirtschaftsministerium und am
Ende hatten wir dann da eine Expertin
sitzen die sagte man hat da drei Puzzle
aber man bekommt sie überhaupt nicht zu
einem Gesamtbild zusammen also sie
können noch nicht mal zum Beispiel sagen
welche CO2 Einsparungen dieses
heizungsgesetz denn nun bringen wird
nun sind diese Prognosen die Zukunft
natürlich immer Prognosen deswegen sind
sie quasi aus ihrer Logik heraus nie
hundert Prozent richtig sondern sie
schaffen eine Perspektive die
hoffentlich eintreten wird und es ist
richtig dass bei dem
bei den deutschlandticket die Schätzung
auseinander gehen man weiß ja nicht oder
man lernt jetzt erst wie viele Menschen
ist in Anspruch nehmen und ob dadurch
auch vor allem Verkehre reduziert werden
oder die Menschen mit dem Deutschland
Ticket nur am Wochenende eine Reise mehr
machen da gibt es verschiedene Annahmen
aber es gibt doch ein korrid oder
Annahmen richtig ist dass die Experten
des Verkehrsministeriums und das
klimaschutzministeriums nicht exakt die
gleichen Annahmen machen aber der ist
davon
also das ist nicht nur so ein bisschen
exakt sondern das ist schon ganz weit
auseinander gehen das ist ja auch nur
ein Symptom dafür dass da eben jeder so
sein Süppchen kocht aber ist noch nicht
mal gemeinsam bezahlen gibt ich
naja ich will aber naja dass ich ein
bisschen anders wir müssen wir haben
eine Lücke bis 2030 von 200 bis 300
Millionen Tonnen sagen wir sage ich
sagte Expertenrat keiner weiß der
Expertenrat nicht und wir nicht ob es
199 Millionen Tonnen sind oder
299 oder irgendwas dazwischen die
entscheidende Botschaft ist ist eine
Lücke da und diese Lücke muss
geschlossen werden und wir haben im
Moment nicht genug Maßnahmen diese Lücke
zu schließen da sind wir politisch
blockiert in einem gewissen Sinne mehr
Maßnahmen viel mehr Maßnahmen kann es
kaum geben wenn es
radikalermaßnahmen gibt wir haben das
beim Gebäude Energiegesetz also dem
heizungsgesetz gesehen dann schwindet
auch schnell die Akzeptanz in der
Bevölkerung also müssen wir in der
Umsetzung besser werden wie schnell
werden die Windkraftanlagen gebaut wie
schnell werden Gebäude saniert wie
schnell werden Genehmigungsverfahren für
die dekaronisierung der Industrie
dargestellt das ist der Weg den wir
gehen müssen und auch gehen können und
dann haben wir noch eine Chance die
Klimaschutzziele einzuhalten bzw die
Lücke zu verringern da habe ganz zum
Schluss noch zwei oder vier Millionen
Tonnen mehr oder weniger sind ist bei
200 oder 300 ja auch ein bisschen egal
bist entscheidend ist dass wir uns nicht
in den falschen Debatten verlieren
sondern die Maßnahmen jetzt auf die
Straße bringen zum Schluss noch eine
aktuelle Frage sie bezeichnen dieses
Interview aus das ist auch das jetzt zum
8:50 Uhr vorhin kam die Meldung vom
Flugzeugabsturz bei den mutmaßlich der
wagner-chef Gregorian an Bord war gibt's
dazu von Seiten des Vizekanzler der
Bundesregierung schon eine Stellungnahme
die kann ich noch nicht geben ich
verfolge die Nachrichten die alle mit
einem gewissen angehaltenen Atem aber
ich habe jetzt keine Erkenntnisse die
ich heute Abend hier in ihrem Journal
darlegen kann also ein bisschen werden
wir uns noch gedulden müssen bis mehr
Klarheit in die Dunkelheit gebracht wird
danke Ihnen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert habe
kann das eben schon erwähnt das Kabinett
hat heute eine Reform der des
Staatsbürgerschaftsrechts auf den Weg
gemacht und damit beginnen jetzt bei dir
die Nachrichten Heinz der gut
integrierte Einwanderer und ihre Kinder
sollen künftig schneller einen deutschen
Pass bekommen wenn sie bestimmte
Voraussetzungen erfüllen das Kabinett
billigte entsprechende Pläne von
Innenministerin Fräser die darin eines
der wichtigsten Reformprojekte der
amperegierung sieht künftig sollen
eingewanderte nach fünf statt wie bisher
nach acht Jahren eingebürgert werden
können Frauen und Männer die schon
besonders gut integriert sind etwa durch
ein Ehrenamt nach drei Jahren außerdem
soll es für alle möglich sein mehrere
Staatsangehörigkeiten zu haben
das Bundeskabinett hat heute auch grünes
Licht für den Entwurf zum sogenannten
selbstbestimmungsgesetz gegeben demnach
soll jeder das eigene Geschlecht oder
den Vornamen einfacher ändern können
durch eine Erklärung beim Standesamt
nach dem bislang geltenden
Transsexuellen Gesetz ist etwa
vorgesehen dass Betroffene Vornamen und
Geschlecht erst nach einem
psychologischen Gutachten und einer
gerichtlichen Entscheidung offiziell
ändern dürfen und dazu später im heute-
nach einer Umfrage der deutschen
Industrie und Handelskammer finden immer
mehr Betriebe nicht genügend
Auszubildende knapp die Hälfte der
Ausbildungsbetriebe im Bereich der ihk-
sei betroffen ein neues Allzeithoch es
gäbe aber auch erfreuliche Entwicklungen
die aktuellen Zahlen von Ende Juli sein
leicht positiv und ein Zuwachs bei den
Ausbildungsverträgen gegenüber dem
Vorjahr möglich
Indien ist erstmal seine Mondlandung
geglückt das Land ist nach den USA der
ehemaligen Sowjetunion und China die
vierte Nation der eine sanfte Landung
auf dem Mond gelungen ist mit der Sonde
Chandra Jahren 3 ist Indien zu dem
weltweit das erste Land das erfolgreich
am Südpol des Mondes landete die wenig
bekannte Südseite wird die Sonne zwei
Wochen untersuchen im Land löste der
Erfolg großen Jubel aus für viele
markierte den Aufstieg Indiens zu einer
raumfahrtnation
Wladimir Putin führt nicht nur Krieg in
der Ukraine und das schon seit 2014
seitdem führt er auch einen sogenannten
hybridenkrieg gegen den Westen mit
Desinformationskampagnen und
Unterstützung populistischer Kräfte
welchen Anteil das an den
Polarisierungen in einer ganzen Reihe
westlicher Demokratie hat lässt sich
nicht beziffern zumindest aber hatte er
einen Interesse daran zu befeuern was
schon da war an grundsätzlichen
Konflikten und Verunsicherungen die
freiheitliche Gesellschaften offen
austragen dann gab es große Ereignisse
wie die flüchtlingskrise 2015 und die
corona-pandemie und spätestens da wurde
das politische sehr privat bis hin zu
Zerwürfnissen in Familien und
Freundeskreisen
damit beschäftigen sich Melanie Haag und
Peter Kunst in ihrer Dokumentation die
Streit Republik
der erste Amtsträger der AFD in
Deutschland kommt mit dem Rad auf den
Dienstwagen will Robert Sesselmann
verzichten und strotzt vor Ambitionen
die Glocke schlägt zur Vereidigung der
Realitätscheck für die Weltrettung kann
beginnen in einer Zeit in der Krisen
Deutschland strapazieren zwei Familien
zwei Generationen auf der Couch sie
sprechen über ihre Konflikte
Überzeugungen und ihre unterschiedliche
Sicht auf die AFD die AFD
Schwächen der anderen massiv aus aber
selbst die Parteien untereinander
nutzten
miteinander zu reden und das Gute
gemeinsam zu machen wird schlecht
geredet Heiko braun Arbeiterkind
eigentlich SPD nah wählt mittlerweile
AFD seit 30 Jahren pendelt der Thüringer
zur Firma in Hessen mit seiner
ddr-ausbildung und seinem Können ist er
hier anerkannt auch als Betriebsrat
vom Kunden allgemein aber fehlt ihm die
Anerkennung der Lebensleistung aus
deutscher
schon das für mich gefühlt
der Osten immer noch anders behandelt
wird wieder Westen also die Anpassung
Ostern West hat wie damals versprochen
von Herrn Kohl nicht funktioniert
blühende Landschaften machen wir also im
Osten wir haben der Boutique damals
vertraut die Probleme die die Leute
bewegen die werden von den meisten der
Politik nicht angenommen und für mich
zählt Podest die Politik Ärger
der Streit um den richtigen Weg was
müssen wir aushalten wo hören wir uns
noch zu wie kommen wir raus aus dem
filterblasen in denen wir uns doch alle
bewegen darüber reden die beiden
Familien auch in der filterblase
ungeschminkt Heiko braun und Tochter
Rebecca aus dem Osten der Republik und
Christiane von Gierke und ihr Sohn Chris
Schnappers er ist afd-funktionär sie
eine grüne und feiert 75
du warst ja bei den 68ern aktiv und hast
die Grünen mit gegründet
aber du hast mich das selbstständige
Denken gelehrt und bitte wer hat dir
selbstständig denkt ist heutzutage ein
linker oder noch schlimmer ein grüner
ich finde man muss die AFD wirklich
bekämpfen aber politisch und nicht mit
Verboten man fragt sich natürlich was
hast Du falsch gemacht oder hast du
irgendwas falsch gemacht kann man denn
das als Eltern überhaupt
letztendlich steuern was bietet die AFD
den Menschen in Ostdeutschland sie
bietet Ihnen glaube ich eine Idee wie
Deutschland sein könnte wie in den 80er
90er Jahren mit einer gewissen
wirtschaftlichen Sicherheit mit einer
guten Infrastruktur naja aber da muss
ich mal sagen also 18 19 Jahre also wir
leben in einer ganz anderen Welt man
kann doch das Rad nicht zurückdrehen
momentan nur
auch im weiteren Westen jammern alle nur
und trotzdem einfach raus in die Welt
und zu sagen okay ich finde das jetzt
scheiße aber jetzt werde ich aktiv und
mach was dagegen und das kann nicht über
Protest Wahl funktionieren Familien sind
wie die Gesellschaft sich aushalten bis
an die Schmerzgrenzen der Toleranz und
gemeinsam eine Mitte finden auch in
einer streitrepublik
die ganze Doku wird morgen Abend
ausgestrahlt nach dem heute-journal sie
können Sie aber auch schon vorab in der
Mediathek abrufen und jetzt geht es bei
dir noch mal weiter
Deutschlands Gamer geben eine Umfrage
zufolge immer mehr Geld für Computer und
Videospiele aus im Schnitt 26 Euro im
Monat berichtet der digitalverband
BITCOM zum Start der gamescom Frank
Bethmann wie groß ist dieser gamesmarkt
inzwischen ja er wächst und wächst und
aus derselben Befragung gehen noch zwei
Dinge hervor nämlich dass die Ausgaben
steigen die Jünger die Spielerinnen und
Spieler sind und dass die Bereitschaft
zunimmt auch im Spiel selbst noch mal
weiteres Geld auszugeben also
beispielsweise für Möglichkeiten um in
der ein oder anderen Spielsituationen
schneller voranzukommen in fremde Welten
eintauchen und den andere Rollen
schlüpfen das lockt Tausende auf die
Games kommen die nach eigenen Angaben
weltgrößte computerspielmesse als fünf
größte Absatzmarkt der Welt ist
Deutschland für die Branche von enormer
Bedeutung die andere Seite der
Spektakels heimische Firmen profitieren
vom Boom kaum nur ein Bruchteil der
milliardenerlöse fließt nach Deutschland
das große Geschäft machen Konzerne wie
Sony Nintendo oder Activision Blizzard
Deutsche entwicklerfirmen haben
Schwierigkeiten damit zu halten weswegen
heimische Unternehmen große Hoffnungen
auf die Games Förderung des
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium setzen die
aber wird im kommenden Jahr gekürzt und
mehr Geld werde es auch nicht geben so
Robert Habeck am Abend bei der Eröffnung
der Messe Frank Widmann vielen Dank
bei der hockeyheim EM in München
Gladbach stehen wie die deutschen Damen
auch die deutschen Herren im Halbfinale
sie waren dann am Abend mit vier zu eins
gegen Frankreich und damit setzten sie
sich in der Gruppe B an die Spitze und
treffen am Freitagabend auf England
bei der Leichtathletik Weltmeisterschaft
in Budapest stand mit dem Frankfurter
joshuaco zum ersten Mal seit 36 Jahren
wieder ein deutscher Läufer in einem
WM-Finale über 400 Meter Hürden er war
am Ende nicht ganz vorne mit dabei
Weltmeister wurde der Norweger Carsten
warholen joshuaco wurde Achter
der Film das Lehrerzimmer eine ZDF
Co-Produktion soll für Deutschland ins
Rennen um den auslands-ostar gehen das
teilte German films die
Auslandsvertretung des deutschen Films
mit nach der Entscheidung einer
unabhängigen Fachjury unter den
gesichteten bewerberfilmen die
Entscheidung ist eine Vorstufe auf dem
Weg zu einer möglichen Oscar Nominierung
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 9 10 13 26 28 45 die Superzahl 6
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und ZDF Text auf Seite 557
Journal weiter unter anderem mit einem
Bericht aus den kanadischen
brandgebieten und um 0 Uhr
Update mit Sandra Maria Krone
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter noch einmal eine
ordentliche Ladung Warmluft bekommen wir
ab aus dem Südwesten Europas das hält
aber nur noch morgen an denn die kühlere
Luft setzt sich allmählich durch und der
Wetterumschwung nahe sozusagen sind sie
in blau die ersten shower und Gewitter
Schauer gibt es dann in den frühstücken
ganz im Westen Deutschlands sonst ist es
aber trocken und die Temperaturen sinken
auf 20 Grad nach Südwesten in deutlich
kühler im Norden hier 12 Grad die
Tiefsttemperaturen morgen dann im den in
den frühen Morgenstunden dann im Westen
Schauer und auch schon Gewitter die sich
im Tagesverlauf entwickeln und kräftiger
sein können auch im Norden das ganze
wandert langsam nach Osten im Osten und
dem Süden dagegen viel Sonnenschein bei
höchsten Temperaturen von bis zu 35 Grad
im Südwesten Deutschlands da ist es am
heißesten ja und die
Werbung vor extremer Wärmebelastung gilt
hier immer noch ansonsten häufig Werte
über der 30 Grad Marke nach Norden hin
nicht so heiß und 23 Grad am kühlsten
noch Richtung Schleswig-Holstein ja und
dann kommt der Umschwung am Freitag hier
ist dann stark Regen größerer Hagel und
dazu Sturmböen mit dabei bei den
Gewittern Temperaturen bis 33 Grad am
Samstag spielen sich die Unwetter dann
hauptsächlich im Süden ab und damit ein
schöner Abend